hey 42 here everybody loves every single
person at some point has that small
moment of bless that changes the rest of
their life and we're not the only ones
even animals have fully monogamous
relationships look they cuddle and
everything but what exactly is love
let's finally answer the question a
perplexed scientist for generations oh
and if you stay long enough I might even
tell you how you can make someone love
you love is free
it can't be owned bought or sold it has
no mass or weight and cannot be touched
yet it is the single most powerful
emotion humans can experience it makes
us do some really stupid stuff sometimes
but it's far more than an emotion it can
physically affect our bodies in some
rather incredible ways for example some
extraordinary research revealed that
when two lovers gaze into each of his
eyes their heart rates synchronize and
beat at the exact same time this graph
shows the heart rate of two individuals
in love whilst their eyes were locked in
a loving exchange the red line shows one
heart beat the blue line the other
notice how their heart rates are so
closely math so much so that the blue
line can barely be seen beneath the red
line love is also a powerful painkiller
in fact cuddling can cure a headache
during the loving embrace two chemical
oxytocin is released in our brains
ovaries and testicles researchers found
that a dose of oxytocin can
significantly decrease headaches and
other pains studies have also shown us
simply looking at a photo of a loved one
can reduce pains by up to 40% so then
what is love well this really depends on
how you look at it some people say love
is down to faith our Puffy's already
decided out of our control that sure
sounds poetic what the process is
associated with love can actually be
extrapolated and explains to a large
extent by science was I should warn you
they
won't be romantic unless statistics turn
you on psychologists have shown that it
takes anywhere between 90 seconds and 4
minutes to decide if you fancy someone
surprisingly being attracted to someone
has very little to do with what they say
research shows that 55% is through body
language 38% is the toll in speed of
their voice and only 7% is down to what
they say in order to properly explain
love we first must break it down into
its three stages lost attraction and
attachment each stage is driven by its
own set of unique hormones and chemicals
a person must go through all three
stages before they can truly be in love
with someone which kind of puts a
spanner in the hole love at first sight
thing the first stage lost is probably
the most biologically simple lost is
driven by the sex hormones testosterone
and estrogen in fact research shows that
women actually have different tastes in
men whilst using contraception women
taking the pill prefer men with more
feminine faces whereas women not using
contraception prefer more masculine men
but what's even more interesting is that
the features that trigger lost in a
person differs between genders research
shows that men are attracted to women
that have a symmetrical face full lips
full breasts and wide hips compared to
their waist size or to put it more
simply an hourglass figure because
statistically curvy women are also the
most fertile in fact there's actually
some math behind this research shows
that in European countries the most
desirable waist-to-hip ratio in women is
0.7 and in South America and Africa its
0.9 on the other hand women prefer men
with broad shoulders under narrow waist
what's most intriguingly one of the most
desirable qualities in a man is a
healthy immune system research shows
that women are subconsciously attracted
to men with healthy faces because this
signals a strong immune system stage 2
is attraction this is the stage when
you're deeply in love and you can't
think of anything
but your new partner scientists think
there are free may neurotransmitters
involved with this state adrenaline
dopamine and serotonin firstly
adrenaline along with the stress hormone
cortisol are released in your body
during the first few weeks of your new
relationship these two chemicals are
responsible for making you sweat
increasing your heart rate and giving
you a dry mouth when you're around your
new love interest secondly your levels
of dopamine increase this gives you an
intense rush of pleasure when you bump
into your new love and it's what makes
you desire them even more increased
dopamine levels also increase your
energy levels and decrease your need for
sleep and food it's actually has a very
similar effect on your brain as taking
cocaine and finally whilst you're in the
attraction stage your levels of the
serotonin neurotransmitter drop
dramatically this causes you to become
obsessed with your new love interest
it's the reason they keep popping into
your fort throughout the day
interestingly the low serotonin levels
experienced by new lovers are remarkably
similar to the low serotonin levels
found in patients with
obsessive-compulsive disorder lastly the
final and most important stage of love
is attachment during this stage the
powerful bond is form that keeps some
couples together for life and makes them
wants to have children research shows
there are two major hormones responsible
for this feeling of attachment oxytocin
and vasopressin both the oxytocin and
vasopressin hormones are released by men
and women when they kiss cuddle and have
sex scientists believe that the more sex
a couple has the deeper their bond
becomes an interesting example of this
can be seen with prairie voles like
humans they indulge in far more sex than
is strictly necessary for the purpose of
reproduction and they also like humans
form stable pair bonds as part of an
experiment scientists gave prairie voles
a drug that suppresses the effect of the
vasopressin hormone something remarkable
happens their bond with their partner
deteriorated immediate
and they no longer protected their
partner from potential new suitors so in
a nutshell the answer to the question
what is love is love is a state of deep
attachment to a fellow human being
caused by a combination of chemicals
specifically testosterone estrogen
adrenaline dopamine serotonin oxytocin
and vasopressin sounds so romantic
doesn't it I do apologize if I have some
what ruins the magic but remember these
are nothing more than scientific
explanations for a set of symptoms and
behaviors associated with being in love
in reality love truly is a seemingly
magical and rather beautiful force of
nature that could never fully be
explained by science but there still a
question of why does love exist what
purpose does it serve evolutionary
scientists believe that love is a
product of evolution the theory goes
like this without love acting us to glue
in a relationship keeping a partner long
enough to reproduce is difficult if love
wasn't a component in most relationships
they most likely wouldn't last longer
than a couple of weeks which means a lot
fewer couples would reproduce it's love
that keeps relationships together for
several years or more long enough for
them to have children which after all is
the ultimate goal of evolution
scientists believe that over millions of
years humans uncertain or for animals
have developed a specific set of
chemical processes to make us feel like
we are emotionally attached to our
potential mating partner thus giving us
an incentive to want to stay together
and ultimately reproduce we however
interpret this as being in one
but you may be thinking if the sole
purpose of love is just an incentive to
reproduce then why do we love our family
under even our pets it all has to do
with the attachment hormone we talked
about before
oxytocin it isn't just released when we
have sex it's also released in somewhat
smaller doses when we simply touch
another person or animal every time we
touch another person and experience this
release of oxytocin we become more
deeply attached to them and who do you
think you came into contact with the
most as a baby that's right your family
ever heard the phrase there's nothing
like a mother's love well there really
isn't during the later stages of
pregnancy oxytocin levels in the mother
surge to UM fathom ibly high levels
these levels peak right at the moment of
childbirth this creates a seemingly
unbreakable bond and unrivaled level of
attachment between the mother and child
but it's not just humans that release
oxytocin scientists have discovered that
dogs and cats among many other animals
also release oxytocin when they come
into physical contact with another
animal or human so good news animal
lovers
this means that your pet really does
love you too
scientists found that the more you
socially interact with your pet the more
deeply they become attached to you
unhand the more deeply they will fall in
love with you so then like I promised
here's how you can make someone fall in
love with you
it's really quite simple find a
potential new suitor it doesn't even
have to be someone you know reveal some
intimate details about your life to them
then stare deeply into their eyes for
four minutes there's a slight chance you
may get a slap but research shows that
more often than not they will feel
strangely attracted to you new york
psychologist Professor Arthur Aron
demonstrated this when he randomly
paired people together from a group of
complete strangers and asked them to
reveal intimate details about their
lives to each other for 30 minutes then
stare deeply into each of his eyes for
four minutes afterwards nearly all of
the couples admit
- feeling deeply attracted to the
stranger whom they had only spent 34
minutes with and following the
experiments one of the couples actually
got married if for some weird reason you
don't feel comfortable imposing your
newly learned Jedi Mind Tricks on a
complete stranger fear not there is some
slightly less insane things you can do
to increase the chances of your crush
falling in love with you
research shows that proximity has a huge
effect on law a study in Ohio showed
that 54% of couples who recently applied
for marriage licenses were separated by
a distance of 16 blocks or fewer and 37%
were less than five blocks apart from
each other the science behind this is
called repeated exposure the more you
see someone or something the more you
like it however this is not always the
case
repeated exposure to another person
amplifies the dominant emotion in the
relationship so if the dominant emotion
is anger or hate they're just going to
dislike you even more but the bottom
line is if you want someone to fall in
love with you you should spend as much
time as possible in their company unless
you really really annoy them research
shows that individuals whom are in a
state of emotional distress are
significantly more likely to fall in law
this state of emotional unease is often
found following the death of a loved one
being in an accident or most commonly
after a painful breakup obstacles are
stand in the way of love can actually
increase the chances of a relationship
forming studies show that attraction is
actually increased when external factors
get in the way a great example of this
is when teenagers start a new
relationship and their parents object it
only makes the teenagers want to be
together even more finally I'll leave
you with these few facts women tend to
find men twice as attractive when they
notice over women are interested in him
also on average a man will spend one
year of his life
staring at women it's also common to
think that men are less emotionally
affected by relationships than women but
statistically
are quicker than women to say I love you
in relationships and contrary to popular
belief recent studies have shown that
men are more emotionally affected when
in relationship ends than women thanks
for the view subscribe for more 42